it's been about a month since I got my
new shiny air pods - with wireless
charging I've been using him almost
every day as a replacement to the
original air pods that have owned and
loved since they're released over three
years ago so what's the verdict wasn't
worth upgrading and spending $200 plus
tax to be honest for me no not really
but there is one group of people who
they do make sense for and I'll cover
that in just a bit leading up to the
launch of these new ear pods there are
quite a lot of rumors health tracking
features sweat resistance really fast
wireless charging and new colors none of
that came true and a lot of people were
upset air pods are everywhere and most
people really love them they even have a
98% customer satisfaction rating which
is quite impressive so with that it's
understandable that three years later we
want some new and updated features
personally I would have loved to have
them in black what we got was some minor
updates we have wireless charging if you
spend 200 bucks hey Siri support and the
new h1 shift to be honest I wasn't
really hyped for the wireless charging
since I really have to charge the case
compared to say a phone but over this
last month I realized that is quite
convenient to just walk into my room and
instead of dropping them on my
nightstand I dropped them on the qi
wireless charging pad and in that way I
never actually feel like I have to
charge them with that said wireless
charging is really slow they accept five
watts just like your standard iPhone
break but take almost twice as long to
charge because wireless charging is less
efficient I tested them side-by-side
with original air pods and after 10
minutes the air pods - only gained 8
percent compared to the original ear
pods plugged in with a court where they
gain 20% as far as quality I figured we
wouldn't get any sound quality
improvements since Apple didn't mention
it and I was already happy with the
sound for an unsealed earbud one thing I
was looking forward to is faster and
more reliable connections with a new h1
ship and better range with Bluetooth 5
the h1 ship does connect notice ly
faster and slightly more reliably as
well one issue I had in the past was
swapping my earphones from my iphone to
the Mac it would take a while and
sometimes I'd have to hit connect a
second time in general air pods to are
faster and more reliable but they're not
perfect with that said even a month
later I'm often shocked how
they can connect air pots too with the
h1 ship also have less latency but you
can't really notice that for music and
video since your iPhone will actually
wait to sync up but this is definitely
noticeable and games as for range it's
not really any better sometimes I leave
my phone plugged into charge in my room
while playing podcasts or music and then
I'll go outside to do some work if I get
halfway down my driveway ear pads one
would cut out and same thing goes for
most of my garage so it's really hoping
for some improvements looking at the
Bluetooth 5 specs the range is rated
quite a bit longer but in my testing it
was practically the same well to get
more specific I got three feet further
with air pods to last let's touch on hey
Siri I've used it a few times when I
didn't have my watch and it works quite
well delays minimal and it's definitely
better than having to double tap to
invoke Siri if you don't have an Apple
watch and you want to have hands-free
control this could be a legit reason to
upgrade but personally for me it's
quicker just to spin the crown on my
Apple watch to adjust volume or lift up
my wrist and ask a question without
having to say that special phrase I
mentioned one group of people that could
really benefit to upgrade from air pods
one to air pods - and those are people
who bought these air pods right when
they came out and I've used them a ton
since then I was really surprised
reading quite a bit of comments from
people that said that the batteries in
the original air pots are now half of
what they used to be and since they love
the air pots so much they don't mind
upgrading to air pods - and getting a
fresh battery if you don't need wireless
charging and I would argue that most
don't you can refresh your original pair
with the newer version that's faster
more reliable and with hey Siri for the
same price as before
actually possibly cheaper than that
thanks to Amazon that now sells them
officially we'll leave a link in the
video description so overall these small
updates are an improvement but for most
people unless your battery is dead or
you can really benefit from hey Siri
upgrading to ear pods - isn't worth it
thank you guys for watching if you want
to see more videos like this one click
that little circle above to subscribe
and also go ahead and check out our
detailed ear pods one versus two
comparison or our galaxy buds worth it
for iPhone users right over here this
has been massive Mac's tech and I'll see
you in the next video